hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1921 World
Chess Championship match between josé
raúl capablanca and Emmanuel aspart this
is game 13 and Capablanca is still three
points in the lead so this is a it's an
interesting game but it's an interesting
game for a specific reason which you
will very quickly see so without further
ado let's check it out we've had enough
of the of the chess960 now let's go back
to the good old Queens gambit declined
capablanca opens with d4 with d5 by
Lasker Knight to f3 and Knight to f6
sorry about that we have C 4 and e 6 by
last pair we've entered the Queens
gambit declined with Bishop to g5 and
now Bishop to e7 III now closing the
structure after developing the bishop
like the wake up a Blanca likes it might
be b7 preparing c5 Knight to c3 and here
Alaska castles we have rook c1
continuing development and rook to e8 by
Lasker we have Queen c2 preparing Bishop
to d3 to put pressure on the h7 pawn and
Alaska takes care of that with h6 with
Bishop to h4 and now c5 couple Blanca
trades once in the center we have C
capture some b5 and now Knight captures
last four offers the trade of pieces
Bishop captor Sonny 7 with Knight
captures back alas prefers this the
Queen characters as less pieces are
getting traded off Alaska would still
enjoy at least some complications in the
position as he still has to catch off
the capablanca three point lead d
captures on c5 Knight captures and now
Bishop to b5 attacking the row kappa
blanka says that before probably would
have been a bit more energetic and also
it's perfectly safe but he says his
three points in the lead and he would
just like you know the title of world
champion and then maybe after he gets
that he will play some interesting games
but okay after Knight captures and c5
with Bishop to b5
last four blocks and now Capablanca just
castles last pair attacks the bishop
with Queen to b6
putting pressure on the bishop and also
if the White Queen moves the beat upon
will also be under attack
so Capablanca like I said if Capablanca
was not three points in the lead if he
was just trying to play play a nice game
he'll probably go Bishop back and then
you know just tuck it in for later and
take it from there but here he just
trade with bunch of characters and
Knights actress and now rook after deep
one
so Capablanca forces are now fully
operational Alaska also has to continue
development
he doesn't like rook a to d8 he probably
wants this rook to keep an eye on the a7
pawn in the case of some Queen to a4 so
there won't be any Queen capture some b2
wink after Sunday 7 or or perhaps
something like that but he decides that
this rogue belongs to d8 and this rook
will at some point come to c8 and here
is the very interesting moment of the
game work of a blanca plays h3 and later
in his analysis he says it's a waste of
time that he should have gone Quinte for
immediately but h3 is not a waste of
time as you'll see for example if you
played Queen to a poor immediately
there's no actual danger of rook
captures on d7 because the last pair can
just capture the b2 point for example
Queen captures on b2 and now you cannot
capture because you lose the broken c1
Queen captures on c1 and you cannot play
rugby 1 because you lose the knight on
c3 now lastly you could play rook to c2
attacking the Queen but then Knight to
c5 and the black is just better now Kabu
Blancas queen is also under attack and
here you don't really have anything much
better than captures captures and now to
get out of this mess you have to play
Queen t8 check and then trade on b2
because if you just go for rook captures
and b2 right away then you get Knight
captures on a4 and you are unable to
recapture the piece because if you
capture then rook to d1 results in mate
after 91 you will just play rook
captures anyone check me so Capablanca
actually had it right when he played h3
it's just a useful move creating yeah
you know some breeding room for the king
and now such combinations are not
possible in Alaska's favor
it brings the rook into the game rook 8
to c8 and only now this couple Blanca
play Queen to a4 and now it's different
because he played the move h3 this this
actually nicely prepares papa Blanca for
Queen to a4 now if lassberg was to go
into Queen captures on b2 it's pretty
much pointless because now Luke c2
attacks the Queen and now you have to
play b5 so a sort of a way of trying to
trade Queens because here the idea of 95
like we've seen in the previous line has
no merit as king has an escape route to
just capture scatterers and now you're
more than welcome to capture here and
after Knight captures now you just
capture the night here of a piece and
rook to d1 is nothing because of King to
h2 so very interesting how and and this
is something that I've seen quite often
during the capablanca saga
capablanca plays a move and then during
the analysis I don't think it was
actually a serious analysis it was maybe
just to cover Wonka I was checking out
the game since he said this was probably
better but the move he played was more
than once at the absolute best the
strongest move recommended by the engine
so capablanca will often play it in his
games and then later he will say oh
maybe maybe it wasn't such a great move
but ok last pair plays Knight to c6 now
and here we have Queen to b5 again kappa
blanka says i'm three points in the lead
let's just trade everything and I'm
gonna enjoy my lead further on last pair
plays a six he offers the Queen trade
with Queen captures Knight captures on
b6 and now just a nice straight on d8
rook captures and Knight captures and
here Capablanca plays Knight to e2 where
Lasker if he doesn't want to trade rooks
he he has to play something like rook to
b8 but then he allows this rook to
infiltrate would rock to c7 which is
something you don't want to do Oh ask
her played King to f8 and here
capablanca played rook captures on CA
with Knight Tetris on c8 and it was in
this position that the players agree to
a draw it's a pair of Knights against a
pair of Knights 4 points on the Kings
side 2 points on the Queen side so an
equal position Capablanca satisfied with
a draw as his 3 points in the lead and
Lasker not eager to put for anything
here as he might even it might even lose
it so he's going to look for
chances in the next game where he has
the white pieces now also I wanted to
mention that the last video in the Coppa
Blanca saga will be the last video in
the Capablanca saga I just wanted to ask
you as we're gonna do a sort of a
conclusion video we're gonna talk a bit
more even after the game about
capablanca and everything that happened
during the saga and after so do you want
that in the video where I will show the
last game between capablanca and last
four or do you want it to be like a
separate video like let's just show the
game and then let's talk about
capablanca in the next video so maybe if
you're interested you're also more than
welcome to comment on that sure that's
the game each to remove waste of time
but not really cover one car was
sometimes funny funny like that but yeah
now I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Patrick pakoda maximum
autumn and Jean Loup for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video so you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the capablanca saga for one
more video checking up on your
suggestions and we are planning our next
big saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day